sanji has the best character arc in one
piece and i will prove to you why so
i've kind of reached a point where i
feel like sanji is the most
controversially discussed character in
all of one piece which let's be honest
really says something i mean basically
every twitter reddit post and every
youtube comment section basically looks
like this
except for you love you guys anyways
even among the dumpster fire that is
large parts of the community the sanji
debate is burning as bright as his
passion which i guess is part of the
issue and as someone whose favorite
character in the story is zorro it would
be very easy for me to add some more
fire to the flame
he's already dead however if i did that
i honestly would be lying because to me
sanji is the most well written character
in all of one piece hi my name is manu
and even though i don't smoke cigarettes
in this video i will not only prove to
you that sanji will leave wano as a
changed man but also clear his and in
extension i guess oda's name of being a
bad writer when it comes to the man with
the curly hair his eyebrows my original
relationship with sanji is probably
similar to yours pre-time skip sanji was
an absolute fantastic character he was
not only a true gentleman but arguably
the most mature member of the crew
scolding luffy for inappropriate
behavior protecting the weaker members
of the crew and even his chivalry had
more of an old-school james bond sort of
vibe
[Music]
during that time deciding who was my
favorite between him zorro and luffy was
practically impossible and also
unnecessary there was a great balance
between the three who had very different
views yes but nonetheless respected each
other protected the crew together and
genuinely deserved the title of the
monster trio i guess some people might
already have been uncomfortable with
sanji's outdated views on women but it
was clearly nothing compared to after
the time skip
welcome sugar coated sanji has been
extremely useless and even worse than
that annoying ever since the straw hats
left for fishman islands through punk
hazard dresrosa and zou while zara and
luffy were getting stronger and stronger
reaching their full potential sanji
often failed to win an important fight
and in many situations was just cringey
to watch for his nosebleed horniness and
at that point i fully agreed with the
people who thought that oda had ruined
sanji's great potential by making him an
annoying and useless joke character with
whole cake island however i was
completely shocked but mostly relieved
to find out that this pitiful version of
sanji i had seen since fishman island
had actually been part of one of the
best character arcs i have ever come
across
[Applause]
[Music]
and the recent developments in wano have
now completely evaporated my remaining
doubt so i can say with full confidence
that sanji has not been ruined just the
opposite i believe oda's betrayal of our
cook including his over-the-top
perviness has been very much on purpose
and will make his growth just the more
impactful once it is complete one of the
fundamental tools for great storytelling
and creating a strong main character is
the so-called heroes journey that you
can see here on the top rights and since
all of the straw heads are designed as
main characters of their own this can be
applied to each and every one of them
which actually would probably be pretty
interesting to do maybe i should make a
series about that the first step in the
hero's journey is the call to adventure
and sanji's adventure starts in the most
heartbreaking way possible he has to run
away from his unloving family that has
physically and mentally abused him ever
since his mother died getting this piece
of backstory was the first real mind
[ __ ] moment i had during whole cake
island that gave so much more context to
his character
[Music]
the second step is meeting a mentor for
sanji this person is of course zeff and
again he has another traumatizing
experience almost starving to death on
an island however other than his family
zeph actually shows love for sanji and
is prepared to die for him he is the
first person since his mother that
treats sanji like a human being and
becomes his new family teaching him
about cooking and what it means to be a
decent person most importantly however
he gives sanji his dream which is to
subscribe to o'hara's channel to get his
weekly fix of next generation anime
contents that and also finding the all
blue this is where luffy comes into play
he recruits sanji into his crew and
gives him a chance to fulfill his new
dream and so he has now crossed a
threshold and has entered the world of
pirates and for a while he overcomes his
trials pretty easily with mr prince and
his lobby and his willingness to take
luffy's pain on thriller bark sanji's
popularity was at an all-time high
and then the first big failure saba odi
however here it's the crew as a
collective or arguably even luffy as a
captain that fails here and so alongside
everyone else sanji grows from this
experience and develops new skills over
the time skip which is exactly where
sanji's downfall in popularity starts
how could that happen well will you look
at that it coincides perfectly with the
lowest point of the hero's journey death
and rebirth
as i summarized earlier sanji comes out
of the time skip massively flawed while
his ratio of coolness to pervert was
maybe something like 80 20 before the
time skip to me it had shifted to
something closer to 90 10 on the pervy
end and i gotta be honest of course that
would overwrite all the good
associations we have made with him
before and even more frustrating he was
basically of no use to the crew anymore
this negative spiral keeps speeding up
until finally we hit rock bottom with
whole cake islands where sanji not only
leaves the crew but even disrespects and
hurts his captain
he is reunited with his abuser family
who used him as a pawn for political
marriage and in the end even has to
learn that his to be bright pudding the
only ray of hope in all of this actually
had been plotting to murder him and
everyone else at the ceremony
you can see how that sanji's lowest
point in the story so far right many
people took this scene as sanji being
heartbroken about pudding not loving him
but it's actually the culmination of his
entire character arc so far literally
pouring down on him and the scene
reflects that pretty perfectly dark
alone and crying and this is where
everything changes and so to really
appreciate sanji's radical development
from here you have to understand the
main point of sanji's second backstory
with the windsmokes that some people for
some reason found irrelevant because
sanji didn't go from awesome to the
state he's in here at whole cake islands
you need to understand this is how sanji
has always seen himself
[Music]
right from the start he had close to no
self-worth as a person which really is
no big surprise given his upbringing i
mean if you got told you were worthless
and treated like an animal for the first
eight years of your life by your nazi
family how would you feel what's that on
the lens oh it's a sponsor well that's
convenient because the last video was
expensive this video is sponsored by
skillshare the sanji of sponsors
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes for all skill levels in tons of
creative and practical disciplines like
filmmaking cooking and art but it can
really be anything recently i've been
trying to get back into cooking and took
this awesome class by elena carp for the
second time actually on how to properly
use a kitchen knife or how about this
course on how to make sushi the first
1000 of you foxes to click the link in
the description below will get a one
month free trial of skillshare so you
can start exploring your creativity
today so the baseline is sanji is the
most self-sacrificial straw hat which is
really impressive given how often one of
the straw hats pulls one of these
moments but while luffy risks his life
for his dream and zoro risks his for his
principles sanji risks his life because
he feels indebted to people and this
behavior is actually established right
from the start during the bharatiya arc
where he refuses to leave the restaurant
because of his felt death to zeff
despite literally being fired
and just a bit later he is prepared to
let pearl kill him for the exact same
reason when he offers everything of
himself to the women he chases he really
means it and the same of course goes for
the straw hats he would rather be alone
and die rather than see his family hurt
the key is that sanji was born with
incredible kindness and altruism
[Music]
his role on the ship is literally taking
care of the crew and making sure
everyone is healthy and happy he always
fights for the weak and it's also the
reason why sanji keeps going on his solo
missions he wants to be of use to the
crew and take care of things on his own
which is actually one of the reasons why
he gets into fights with zorro who
fights for everyone in battle but
otherwise spends his time on the ship
sleeping and training so yes kindness is
inarguably sanji's most important traits
however combined with his abusive and
traumatic childhood he is not able to
extend that love and care to the one
person that needs it the most himself i
think someone compared that to this
scene from fire force that i found
incredibly fitting here as well
and at the same time i also believe that
sanji's pervineness and sexism come from
the same good place as well the only two
people who showed him love as a kid were
his sister and his mother who both were
dominated by his father and brothers
[Music]
so no wonder he would put a woman on a
pedestal and see them as something
beautiful that needs protection from men
and the second half of his life he then
grew up in a family of only dudes all of
them tough guy sailors so of course he
would get that extra portion of matcha
with that as well when you really think
about it sanji grew up on c his entire
life in a way he is the most piratey
crew member well except jimbei he
literally lives in the ocean
who lives in a pineapple under the sea
and don't forget that sanji spent two
years on okama island chased around 24 7
which is literally the reason why oda
made him go overboard with all the
intolerable nosebleed stuff after the
time skip and with that knowledge going
back to the rainy night on whole cake
island sanji's insecurity and lack of
self-worth have pulled him to rock
bottom his perviness is not charming
anymore but annoying his solo missions
aren't successful anymore but a burden
he has disrespected his crew and captain
only to find out it was all for nothing
and as the crowning pile of [ __ ] on top
he's back with the ungrateful
emotionless family that caused this
entire mess in the first place
and looking at our chart it is here that
sanji finally has his first big
revelation he finally understands that
going off on his own was a mistake that
there are women out there who would
exploit his chivalry that he
disrespected luffy and that his desire
to save people on his own is actually a
burden on those he cares for but maybe
the most heartbreaking thing is that he
finally understands that luffy and the
others came to save
him that he was not dispensable that
they cared so much for him that they
would declare war on a yonko sanji cares
so so much about the people he's close
to both the straw hats and zeph but it
doesn't seem to occur to him that they
care about him just as much what really
broke my heart is that he's genuinely
surprised when luffy bombs into whole
cake island to rescue him even though
literally anyone could have predicted
that in a heartbeat i mean sanji has
witnessed luffy go through hell and back
for nami robin vv and ace for ice
actually multiple times i guess and he
still doesn't expect that he's worth the
same level of concern until that moment
where he sees luffy starving and beaten
waiting at the very spot he promised he
would wait
[Music]
whole cake island was sanji's arc
because he finally realizes his flaws
just as luffy did with robin nami and
usopp he makes sanji shout out his true
feelings to him and liberates him from
his emotional prison
luffy and the others love him for who he
is and so sanji saves the day in whole
cake island by being the kind person
that he actually is winning over
pudding's heart saving his family and
even baking the cake to stop big mom's
rage and save all of his enemies and
this phase of growth has carried all the
way over to wano spoiler alert from here
on out by the way one of my favorite
moments during the raid so far has been
sanji calling robin for help when
captured by black maria trusting robin
to fight black maria while holding on to
his values means he now thinks of robin
as a strong and reliable person instead
of a damsel in distress that needs to be
saved and kept out of danger he
swallowed his pride and asked a woman to
save him even though he always has been
the one saving women throughout the
series and i realized that this scene
stands in direct contrast to his
standoff with khalifan and his lobby
where he refused to trust inami i mean
just look how grateful robin is for this
gesture she's beaming and marco gets it
too so now sanji is getting his
long-awaited fight with queen however
the issue of self-worth still remains
while he has overcome the trauma of his
upbringing in whole cake island he still
detests his family and now that his own
vinsmoke abilities have awakened he
feels disgusted and is scared to lose
his emotions even though luffy told him
to his face that he needs the kind sanji
he now is wondering whether luffy might
not prefer a heartless machine to fight
for him and so what sanji now needs to
realize is that his powers are already
the opposite of germa queen said that
judge wanted his kids to have hearts of
ice but who stopped his plans sanji's
mother sora who sacrificed herself and
gave sanji a burning heart of kindness
the exact opposite to judge's plans with
this panel during the wedding many
readers only see sanji saving his family
but i see sanji and his mother saving
them all with sanji's burning hearts a
really nice not to this is actually
sanji's slider that looks suspiciously
like his mother giving him fire by the
way there's actually a real world
version of this lighter that was made as
a special collaboration where only about
a thousand of these were made and i
really need to get my hands on one of
these the next really huge step in his
development that i think people kind of
overlooked in this recent chapter is
that sanji chose to destroy his raid
suit that was a power i guess people
disliked to begin with as it turns out
oda only meant it to be a catalyst for
sanji's true power up however much more
importantly with this sanji also starts
to overcome his arguably worst trait of
them all his pervineness destroying the
one thing his perverted mind always
craved for
in the end sanji will realize that he's
actually most successful with women when
he is his true kind and caring self no
matter if it's viola or pudding sanji is
starting to understand that true
chivalry is much closer to the cool and
caring spy hero side of him that we all
fell in love with to begin with and in a
more metaphoric sense by destroying the
raid suit he literally chooses not to
hide anymore but be the crewmate that
luffy needs by embracing who he is at
heart which is exactly what is gonna
happen by the time wano is over but and
i think this is very important he still
has to atone for what he did on whole
cake island especially in front of zorro
and speaking of zorro if you want a
deeper understanding of his character i
strongly encourage you to watch my
analysis on him